introducing zim a mobile app for Windows
iOS and Android phones that lets you
share your photos not your phone getting
started is easy take your source
select your photos
and dad people from your phone's contact
list or by email or phone number
friends will receive a text message with
a link to visit
everyone invited to the Zen swipes pans
and zooms together for a fun
synchronized experience best part only
one person needs to have the app
installed if you do have the app you can
also add photos to any sim
you can also exchange simple messages
or add people for even more fun and
conversation one last thing to know
Zim's expire after a little while so
there's no store to a management
overhead to worry about just sit back
and enjoy the show
you